this is the moment Pakistan's opposition
leader Imran Khan was arrested at the
high court in Islamabad he is facing
dozens of charges including corruption
and misuse of power Han's party says the
charges are politically motivated it was
a blatant interference in the judicial
Affairs by the powers they be and he was
taken in uh let's see what the reaction
is going to be but this is this is in
violation of all all laws and rules
contained in the statute book you know
and I I think
um the Rangers uh were the Fortuner that
took him and and I we understand you
know that that they are not directly
controlled by the government and power
they are controlled by other forces you
know which are considered to be above
the law in this part in this country
trust case maintains that when he was in
office Han illegally benefited from a
real estate Tycoon and allegedly wiped
nearly 200 million dollars off of
Pakistan's economy the interior Minister
says harness failed to appear before the
court several times and was arrested by
the national accountability Bureau for
losses cost to the National Treasury
fund supporters have started protesting
in various cities police in Islamabad
have banned all gatherings
the coalition government denies its
targeting the opposition leader and has
urged him to respect the judicial
process he had been issued
notices
respond or appear in person as was
required as has been the practice of
everybody who has been arrested by
national accountability Bureau during
his own term and power most of the
arrests that were made imbran's terms
were in under the national
accountability bureau's act which was
much harsher than what it is now
Han was shot and wounded in November he
has accused the Prime Minister interior
Minister and a general in the
intelligence agency for orchestrating
the attack
on Monday a rare rebuke from the
military warning Khan to end what it
calls a pattern of leveling fabricated
and malicious allegations as well as
Sensational propaganda against State
institutions
no democratically elected prime minister
has ever served a full term in Pakistan
and our controversy is brewing about
elections later this year
analysts say Pakistan's public opinion
has never been as divided and after the
popular Leader's arrest tensions are
likely to flare
joins us on the line from the Pakistani
Capital Islamabad and Kamal when we
spoke to you last hour things were
getting tense as more and more
protesters were taking to the streets
are things continuing to escalate there
in fact there has been a major
escalation we have reports of major
protests in the city of Karachi
unprecedented development also given the
fact that hundreds of supporters were
able to get inside the Gate of General
headquarters that the headquarters of
the powerful military are also questions
being raised by the legal fraternity and
also the Islamabad High Court chief
justice who said that this was an attack
uh on the court itself
paramilitary forces arrested the former
prime minister from inside the premises
of the Court as we appeared for
extension of bail uh this of course is
seen by the judges as making a mockery
of the Pakistani justice system uh the
Pakistani the court also the judge also
ordering that the director general of
the national accountability should
appear before the court he also asked
the Police Inspector
asked him as to how was uh if the former
prime minister arrested from inside the
premises of the court so uh the court
also saying that if you had to arrest
him you could have arrested him from
outside uh the situation engaged now
escalating because we have reports of
protests across the country and all the
provinces and also reports that the
supporters have been able to enter into
the co-commanded residents in the hall
uh this is the major the lieutenant
General's residence in the hall uh so
considerable anger as far as Imran Khan
supported the concerned and the
situation escalating by the hour and
Imran Khan spoke out a couple of days
ago about certain military leaders is
his arrest today a direct result of that
um I could you repeat that the lines
seemed to be disturbed could you come
back with that question sorry yes of
course Khan spoke out a couple of days
ago about certain military leaders is
his arrest today a direct result of that
will definitely uh Imran Khan had said
earlier two days ago uh that uh he named
basically a senior military officials uh
in the uh in the services intelligence
saying that he was directly involved in
the assassination attempt on him that
there was a plan to assassinate the
former prime minister in the judicial
complex when he appeared earlier as well
and he said that it was the same officer
who was also involved in the murder of a
prominent Pakistani gen uh journalist
arshad Sharif in Kenya so
um after that the military issued a
statement saying that nobody has the
right to undermine uh the military and
of course the military coming out quite
strong but the former prime minister
then said that it was not against the
institution but but against some Rogue
elements within the Pakistani military
so indeed that all to possibly has
created quite a lot of resentment with
his supporters and therefore we are now
seeing uh scenes of the public going in
for General headquarters as well okay
thank you so much that has come out
harder for us in Islam about